[Music]
hello and welcome to marshall matters
with me winston marshall today i'm
joined from california by one of the
greatest american songwriters of all
time don mclean
dawn's songs have resonated through the
ages and have been covered by the likes
of madonna george michael ed sheeran and
elvis presley
and i love you so
vincent and of course american pie are
all firm favorites in the american
songbook the latter american pie
released 50 years ago in 1971 might even
be considered an alternative national
anthem
it was voted number five song of the
20th century in the u.s
the original working manuscript from
american pie sold for 1.2 million
dollars at christie's this is testament
not only to the power of don's music but
to the power of his lyrics don thank you
so much for joining me
thank you for having me what a lovely
introduction
i'm generally thrilled i i i remember
singing your songs even as a as a boy i
think i have a memory of being at a
wedding age five or six and seeing all
the adults taking their ties off uh the
men taking their ties off dancing on the
table singing singing american people
yeah
that has the effect on people exactly
party time
yeah exactly this must be unbelievable
for how to have a song even resonate
with one other person but to resonate
with so many people
year after year decade after decade
there's it's very few songwriters could
even imagine that having that experience
well i i guess it has a
sort of a prismic effect you know you
see things in it as you grow older and
it stays with people um
i had a lot of fun writing the song and
actually
all the songs on the american pie album
and making that album was magic
um
even the cover the cover was fantastic
the guy that took that was
the cover is almost as famous as the
song
so yeah it was it was a very wonderful
time and uh
i was
you know immersed in a world of um
a lot of contradictions because
there was a lot of music being made a
lot of really good music and there was a
lot of very
ugly political
um
stuff in the streets you know
people
getting
tear gassed and
uh terrible riots and
and had been going on for years and
years in america it was a real
really wide open town you know and i
made my first album in
berkeley california and
um tapestry
the guys would come you know and they'd
been gassed by the police wow you know
when they got to the to the session
so you're right in the middle of it so
yeah so your first two albums tapestry
and american pie and and they were and
they were
made at the tail end of the civil rights
movement is what you're referring to in
the anti-war movement the anti-war moves
so this is yeah this is the height of
the vietnam war civil rights movement
morphed
into the anti-war movement in a strange
way
it's kind of like prohibition
morphed into women's rights um in back
in the 1930s
their 20s
it just happens that way you know things
don't stay static
and but it was very uh tumultuous
and so i
you know i was caught up in that
and
i was really
i think
took my job seriously
you know as a songwriter and a singer
because i knew
how much a song could mean to people
if it was the right song
and
so i took it seriously i didn't see it
as being an entertainer
or
you know particularly a show busy
type of a person i saw it
you know i like
entertaining people and i like singing
for them but there was always
information
you know that i'd like to get across
whether it was
a song about poverty or a song about
the the environment or whatever
you've got very beautiful songs about
vietnam war
1967 one and and yes the grave as well
yes and and were those i think actually
george michael sang a very beautiful
version of the grave uh but uh those
songs protest songs as well i mean
they're clearly more informed lamenting
the tragedy of of of war well you know a
protest song
uh dylan call those finger-pointing
songs
uh they're different really from those
two songs that you mentioned
because
there are
um
portraits really
of
relationships in 1967 you know it's
his buddy joe who was brought back in
the in plastic
and he talks about it
and the other song is a man
you know it's a dream that i had you
know that i was in a foxhole all of a
sudden i was in my own grave
you know and i realized that that that i
wonder how many guys
you know in the middle of this horrible
experience realize holy mackerel you
know i'm already eight feet underground
you know and and gonna if i die here i'm
already buried
you know and um
so it's these kind of concepts rather
than
uh pointing the finger at lbj or nixon
which was
very hard not to do you know in those
days but
so was it about
capturing the mood of the time and and
and
was there
did you sense a sort of responsibility
in
in uh collecting the human aspect you
know it's the humanity of it
rather than
the abstraction of you know this is
wrong and we must end this and this kind
of thing you know it's the hum making a
human
and that's always the key
you know to any great movie it doesn't
matter what it is it's
it still comes down to personalities
and and the interaction between
characters
and there's someone i
really want to ask you about because he
was
i believe a friend of yours at in that
period and and it's pete seeger and uh
i'm sure the spectator won't be thrilled
about me promoting famous communists but
he wrote a brilliant book on banjos
which uh for me helped me when i was
starting the banjo and i still would
recommend it absolutely to anyone
wanting to start that instrument but um
uh he was he i'm right understanding he
was a friend of yours
yes um he
helped me get my start
i was i wrote
how to play the five string banjo that
was a little
book that he put out in the
i think he mimeographed the first ones
yeah
and he was very good at
finding wood cuttings and
different
artistic things to put in there he was
an excellent
teacher he really was a teacher more
than anything and he wrote a book about
how to play the the guitar and how to
play the
steel drums and how to make the steel
drums out of a uh an oil drum yeah so
you know he liked to pass this
information on and get these books made
and
but the fun for me was that i
i had been writing him since baby junior
high school
because i fell in love with the weavers
and
i still am in love with the weavers and
i knew all of them got to know them very
well
and
back then
you know i read how they had been
blacklisted as a little boy you know 14
years old in neuroshell new york i
didn't know anything about the blacklist
you know
that was much too intellectual for me
but what i did was i wrote away to
washington
and asked for
transcripts of the house on american
activities committee
and they sent me a big box from
washington
and i was my mother
i was 15 at the time and it got
delivered to my mother said donnie what
is this you know i said oh just some
stuff from washington
i want to see what they're saying what
kind of questions they're getting asked
you know and
so that's how deep i would get into
things i'm still that way today you know
if i if i have a pursuit i'll get way
into it you know all the way
so
the next step really was i had to get to
know these people
so i got to know i called fred
hellermann who was the guitar player
in the group on the phone
and just cole called him when i was 15
and got to be his friend and every
month or two i would give him a call and
talk to him he was very nice and
next thing i knew i i got to know lee
hayes and then
eric darling who was the replacement for
pete seeger and the weavers and
tremendous banjo player
and so the fun was
watching them play
because i was there sitting
and i would ask him how do you do this
how do you wear your finger picks how do
you
get that and show me exactly how he did
it and the same thing happened with with
pete
so i would say how do you do that you
know when he was oh it's just like this
you know and
it was the most wonderful thing you know
to have
the man right there
because you know you used to have to
watch
if they were on tv and try to figure out
what was going on and you really
it's very hard to note from a book
you know how something's supposed to
sound
when you're right there and you hear it
and then you you say how do you do that
and he shows you
i mean i'm telling you it was the most
fun
and i
i love the five string banjo um there's
i'm i'm glad that you play that you you
played that instrument
and um i played it a lot back in the
1960s and 70s in fact i used to do
recording sessions
i'm on a bunch of records i'm on some
clancy brothers albums and i'm on uh
a red bone elm leon redbone there's one
called um
on the track
and i play on poli wally doodle playing
banjo and i do some damn good work on
poliwally doodle i gotta say it sounds
like a very uh encouraging and nurturing
environment that you were you were in at
from a very young oh yes
i was used to having everything knocked
down
by my my father my father and mother
really didn't
know anything about
show business or
any of that i can't tell you how
far away they were it was they were we
were really nice people and very good
parents and
and they loved me a lot but there was
not a lot of joy
in the house um
so this music
you know brought this wonderful joy
to me you know their singing
and then i discovered so many other
artists as a result
and you know josh white and the way we
play guitar still fascinates me
um and so many others
and of course i loved electric guitar
too that's why i love buddy holly you
know and um
yeah
i love great singers so i loved elvis
presley and
marty robbins and
roy orbison um so i was full of music
and you know and i really didn't know
where to turn
you know what did i want to do did i
want to be in a group i didn't want to
be by myself
did i want to i thought at one point i
wanted to be a
flamenco guitar player i love carlos
montoya you know i realized how hard
that was
and the folk thing you know
kind of suited me
because you could do a lot of different
things and the same with the banjo
you could have a lot of different
strums and techniques and things that
you could use
so i was got good at collecting those
you know having more and more of those
and then the folk thing came along uh
with little nightclubs everywhere
you know where you could go in and there
were a lot of people like me you know
who didn't
do much they weren't that good they were
learning new york city yeah this would
be in new york but they were all over
they were in colleges everywhere there
was a little coffee house you would play
you could make a hundred dollars
you know and i i was supporting my
mother at the time and
120 dollars was her rent so if i just
did one of those i could almost make her
rent
for her and then i
i was always busy doing these things and
then i
became an opening act to all these
big big stars you know like steppenwolf
and
that was in 69
and started to get wider and wider into
show business you know and um
with the first album tapestry then it
broke loose then i was
played on the underground radio a lot fm
and i was doing concerts in colleges and
and learning how to perform you know how
do you do this
so i kind of knew how i was always sort
of pretty good but
you know there was i had a lot to learn
yeah
um uh
i was very curious as well uh this might
be a small uh
story within it all about your doing the
hudson river uh was it the sweet water
boat uh
um it's well it seemed to me one of the
first environmentalist
uh
protests uh uh from within the music
industry led by sega but since that's
come now is is one of the most uh talked
about issues of the day it's you were
sort of way ahead of of your time uh
five decades ahead of your time really
yeah i had to be there um it was so
i like information and i'm fascinated
with intelligence
uh there's so much stupidity around now
it really is offensive to me
the things people say and the
the slogans they believe in and just so
dumb
but he was
so interesting to be around because
um
this is before he built his boat the
hudson river sloop
i helped raise money for that i got
started with him in 1966
when i was still in college
and but i as i say i had written him
since i had been like 15.
and so he knew about me and he would
always answer my letters i'd get it
maybe a year later but i get an answer
and um give me good advice you know and
um
so after i finally met all the other
weavers i got to i i i met him
in about 1966
and then again for real in 1968
because
i
the following year i got a job singing
on the hudson river
sponsored by the new york state council
on the arts
and i sang in every river town
starting where the hudson starts so here
i was in the middle of this getting a
lot of publicity and here he was doing
this
thing so we i met with him and he was
nice enough to include me
uh in some early festivals that they
were doing
and and and then you know they would
bring scientists out on stage
to talk about what was going to happen
in 50 years if we didn't straighten out
and here it's 50 years later and
everything they said is happening wow
yeah everything
i go and i look at see these ice caps
melting and see the rivers the the water
rising it's every single thing
i knew 50 years ago
wow
you said just a moment ago
as all these slogans people are now
believing i'd be curious to know what
sort of slogans you're referring to then
but i also wanted to ask you i've heard
you say recently uh as uh that uh
political correctness is is a new type
of fascism which i found quite a
poignant
thing to hear from you particularly in
it be you being friends with sega who
was blacklisted by the government yeah
well um i think here's what i think um
i believe that um
i believe that the the metoo movement
uh started when women which was an
empowering women
and they'd had enough of being exploited
in
corporate situations and harvey
weinstein was a guy who
behaved just like
cohen at columbia pictures what was his
name um can't think of it
but these guys were all
the casting couch that's what they did
so but women had enough
so he got his
and then they started picking a whole
bunch of other people who were doing
this kind of thing and they made
examples of them all good idea to do you
don't have to have this
in the environment
that
i think
then you have the
the death of george floyd and then you
had this whole thing where black people
were just sick and tired of being shot
you know uh for doing very little
over and over this was happening and
finally it was symbolized by
and then
of course that moved into pulling down
these confederate statues
and getting rid of the confederacy once
and for all in their flag
which i find offensive so i was
perfectly on board with that
this is a good thing
and it was those statues were put up in
order to frighten black people and let
them know that we that the white people
still had control in the south and to
you know
um you know watch your step
and that's what those statues really
were for
and so they should come down
and this
the flag should be
not flying on
uh state property and so on that's the
good thing
but now it's started to i think there's
been a certain
aspect of this where people are a little
bit drunk with power
you know well we'll kill that and we'll
kill this and
so
in a funny way
you know i
i sometimes
think um
well we've canceled the environment
you know we've canceled the animal
kingdom i mean
certainly more than 60 of all the
species in the world are gone in the
last 50 years
we're canceling the oceans because
there's so much nitrogen and plastic
that
fish can hardly exist
we've canceled god we've canceled
religion we've canceled civility
we've canceled the english language
um
you know in a sense isn't that what
american pie says isn't that the day the
music died isn't that the day we're in
and so as this song comes back again
you know which these songs tend to do
it's talking about
all of this stuff that's
been canceled it's it's on this day you
know this is the day the music died
so that's
that's what i think
and uh i've seen this coming
to some degree with songs like head room
and prime time
you know which is about
seeing all your experience through the
television and um
um and music being made by
robots i mean i i think that people
don't make music
really anymore and that the
the recording studio lies
you know the camera and the recording
studio are now liars
because everything is photoshopped and
everything is fixed up and you can't
tell
but in the old days if you went in the
studio you'd better be ready
you know to do your very best work today
because
the meter is running and the other
musicians there
are very very good and they don't make
mistakes
and you better be at your best
you don't have to do that anymore
everything is
fixed up later and phoned in and
computer part is sent in
so in a sense my song coming as it does
now
is in a way a sort of an anti-cancel
culture anthem in a sense or at least
it's telling people hey this is what
we're in you know
at the beginning of this conversation
you said you talked about um the the
more thing from uh the civil rights
movement into vietnam and these things
and now you're describing again in this
era the metoo movement uh morphing into
um black lives matter protests and it is
in
over there in america
and having gone through both those
experiences do you see parallels
between them or well i think i
the one thing that i i can't understand
is that
the
the idea of cancel culture
and political correctness
has made people afraid on both sides to
say anything
so this is the big difference as i see
it between now and those days in the
1960s everybody was very out front about
how they felt about everything
today you really don't know how people
feel
because they're afraid to say something
because they're afraid they'll be
criticized or
you know they'll offend somebody
nobody cared about offending anybody in
the 1960s
people realized that you know their
point of view
was not going to be agreed to by
everybody
and that if that was too bad
because we didn't agree with their point
of view so everybody was offended
but now there's this
primitive kind of
reaction to offending people
that has completely
closed off the college campuses
to comedians for sure
they can't go on a college campus
because they can't say anything
you know or they're going to
offend somebody
and um
and then they're going to get in trouble
like dave chappelle
is now the poster boy
for that and um i looked at his special
the closer i didn't see anything
offensive with it
you know he was very gentle about
everything and
very funny
but
you know but chappelle is a similar
category to yourself where he's somewhat
uncancelable
and
you guys can i suppose i think say what
say what you want whereas perhaps there
are younger artists or maybe i should
ask do you think what are the
consequences of of this so-called cancer
culture for us i i never thought about
that
you know
i said what i wanted to say
and and and the consequences be damned
and to some real extent i'm still the
same way
because i'm too old
you know to have any of this hurt me all
that much
you know
i'm i roll along and
so i say what i want to say
and
but i think that when you have that kind
of a chilling effect
uh where you don't really know
what
might happen
and especially not if you're an artist
because an artist can
always find a home somewhere but if
you're a regular working person
you know in you can imagine the
environment in the office
you know you said something wrong you
know you made a comment about it i look
good today i'm telling the boss you know
i mean chris matthews
was one of my favorites he was on msnbc
for 20 years hardball was his show
and he was flirt flirty you know he
would say you look beautiful or i'm in
love with you or something like that
got him fired they just yanked him right
out of the seat and took him by the ear
and put him in the street
for being for saying benign things you
know nothing
bad at all
so it sends a message okay
don't compliment anybody
you know
and more and more we
closing that civility
and uh you can't really
be say anything and so i think that
that's a big difference from the 1960s
is that you knew what people
people offended everybody all the time
are you kidding um
you ever see the fire sign theater they
were a funny group they did a bunch of
albums on columbia
they were hilarious and they had all
these
comedy troops you know that
second city and
snl came out saturday night live came
out of that and there was canada they
had um
another group of people and they bet
produced martin short and
john candy and
all of those guys came from canada
they didn't say anything
you know and do anything
and that's what made it so much fun
yeah
well let's end on a more positive note
um
what are you excited about and what is
next for mr don mclean
well i've got a lot of work to do i've
got a i've got to get this
album out next year i've got to get
our children's book launched
in
april and we have peter gallagher the
television
who's on the show zoe's list i don't
know what the full name of that is but
he's very popular he's he's done the
audio book version of it
i've got to do a big world tour
which is going to take me to probably
over a hundred cities maybe more
and then and i've got uh
um
plenty of other things you know going on
and and
you know and what'll happen is one thing
kind of leads to the next you know
somebody will pop up somewhere and say
um
oh yeah well there's also a broadway
show that they're
uh planning which will use a lot of my
songs
uh in a musical broadway type of thing
we've got that all
contracted for and they're out there
as well so
fantastic well uh don thank you so much
for your time um i wish you all the
the best and uh and great success for
all these various projects and well
great to talk to you and thank you for
having me on your show
thank you so much don
[Music]
you